inciso d sea igual a 6 entonces
fx es igual a 1 entre x cuadrada menos
6x encuentra la descomposición de la
función f en fracciones parciales y
después encuentra la integral de fx de x
muy bien entonces primero lo que voy a
pensar es en cómo voy a encontrar la
descomposición de la función f en
fracciones parciales y bueno para eso lo
que voy a hacer es apuntar primero aquí
a mi función
efe efe de x pero esta vez voy a
factorizar la parte de abajo la parte de
abajo me va a quedar como uno entre y
abajo me queda x que multiplica a x
menos 6 muy bien y quiero escribir esto
como y ojo esto es muy importante porque
justo en este momento voy a buscar la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
porque lo que quiero es escribir esta
función de la
a am / x
un cierto ve un cierto ve entre x 6 x
menos 6 y lo que quiero encontrar son
los valores de am y de b y bueno la idea
es esta
qué pasa si tengo que sumar estas dos
fracciones
bueno pues tengo que encontrar un
denominador común y el mejor común
denominador es el producto de estas dos
expresiones entonces a esta primera
expresión a esta primera fracción la voy
a multiplicar tanto arriba como abajo
por x menos 6x menos 6 en la parte de
arriba y también voy a multiplicar la
parte de abajo por x menos 6x menos seis
muy bien y ahora a esta segunda fracción
la voy a multiplicar tanto arriba como
abajo por equis
tanto arriba como abajo por equis para
que así tengan este denominador común x
que multiplica a x menos 6 ok y si ahora
sumó estas dos que me va a quedar bueno
ni denominador común es x que multiplica
a x menos seis muy bien y arriba me
queda si distribuyó está me va a quedar
a x menos seis veces am más b x y bueno
yo quiero que esta expresión de aquí sea
igual a 1
ojo si todo esto es completamente
desconocido extraño o confuso para ti te
encargo que vayas a la sección de
fracciones parciales en la canaca de
ming y vea los vídeos sobre este tema
ok veamos lo que quiero es obtener una
app y una vez tal que esta parte de aquí
arriba sea igual a esto de aquí esto sea
igual a 1 entre x que multiplica a x
menos 6 y si observas si quiero que
estos dos sean iguales lo primero que
tiene que pasar es que estos términos
que tienen x se tienen que cancelar
porque aquí abajo
no tenemos términos con x entonces me
quedarían que a x más bx tiene que ser
igual a 0 no tenemos ningún término en x
aquí o bueno esto mismo lo puedo ver
como a más
tiene que ser igual a cero eso quiere
decir que ya trabajé con este y ya
trabajé con este y me queda este de aquí
y este que es mi término constante tiene
que ser igual a 1 am y terminó constante
de este lado
entonces me va a quedar que menos seis
veces am esto tiene que ser igual a 1 o
bueno de aquí ya puedo decir que am
tiene que ser igual si / de ambas partes
entre menos seis me va a quedar uno
entre seis negativo menos un sexto y
entonces observa si es igual a menos un
sexto entonces ven tiene que ser el
negativo de eso debe de ser un sexto
porque menos un sexto más b tiene que
ser igual a cero o si subo un sexto de
ambos lados me va a quedar que ben tiene
que ser igual a un sexto lo único que
hice fue sustituir este valor de amd
justo aquí en esta ecuación para así
obtener el valor de ve muy bien ahora
que ya tenemos el valor de amd y el
valor deben entonces puedo escribir
a esta función de x a esta función de x
original ahora la voy a escribir de la
siguiente manera la voy a escribir como
a entre x pero vale menos un sexto
entonces me quedaría menos un sexto a
esto lo voy a dividir entre x y bueno yo
sé que esto lo puedes escribir de otra
manera tal vez lo pude haber escrito
como menos 1 entre 6 x pero escrito de
esta forma nos va a ayudar y además así
podemos ver claramente que este es
nuestro valor de a a esto le voy a sumar
ben / x menos 6 pero me valía un sexto
entonces me quedara un sexto entre x
menos seis muy bien y justo esto que
tengo aquí es la descomposición de la
función f en fracciones parciales es
justo la primera parte de lo que
buscábamos en esta pregunta pero después
dice encuentran
integral de la función fx de x y qué
creés para evaluar esta integral
indefinida vamos a usar la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
así que déjenme bajar un poco en la
pantalla para que lo hagamos justo aquí
lo que voy a hacer es tomarme la
integral la integral de la función
f x
de equis pero ahora voy a escribir a
esto como la integral de y voy a
utilizar esta función
fx escrita en fracciones parciales voy a
poner aquí la integral de un sexto esto
entre x + o espera es un sexto negativo
ya esto le voy a sumar un sexto esto
dividido entre x menos 6 y así voy a
poder encontrar más fácil esta integral
bien y esto va a ser igual y cuál es la
anti derivada de esto de aquí bueno la
anti derivada de uno entre x es el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x así que esto me va a quedar como menos
un sexto que multiplica el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x muy bien
ya esto le voy a sumar
un sexto y ahora cuál es la anti
derivada de 1 / x 6 bueno podemos usar
sustitución pero tal vez sea más fácil
pensar que la derivada de x menos seis
es uno y justo lo tenemos acá arriba
entonces cuál es la anti derivada de uno
entre x menos 6 bueno pues eso va a ser
lo mismo que el logaritmo natural de el
valor absoluto de x menos 6
a esto hay que sumarle una constante no
lo olvides
estamos haciendo una integral indefinida
y por lo tanto hay que sumarle al final
una constante y ya está esto de aquí es
la integral de la función fx de x esto
de aquí es la integral de la función fx
de x y observamos que la descomposición
en fracciones parciales nos fue muy útil
para poder encontrar muy fácilmente esta
integral ya que si quisiéramos encontrar
esta integral desde el principio desde
esta función que tengo aquí bueno pues
sería muy fácil encontrarla si usamos y
es justo lo que nos dicen la
descomposición de la función f en
fracciones parciales